hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay
I went around I jumped around a bit
cooled off a bit so I'm ready I'm ready
I'm good let's keep going I'm not ready
I'm not ready I'm not ready anymore
I was ready before but I'm not ready now
oh boy oh boy who's behind me oh boy yes
save save Oh
oh okay oh man I did not like that I do
not like that at all okay
Oh Oh some dude with a chainsaw
ah ah be more scared guy oh oh
what is wrong with you oh oh baby baby
baby
haha I don't need I know need light I
don't need light I do not need light
okay dodge reload reload buddy load okay
I can get this what the hell just kneel
down home and you like to look like the
cop okay bullets aren't doing jack try
the knife
there we go that's not doing oh there's
somebody on his back eyeball is back
okay
okay I want to get tired out if I
trying to just dodge them
okay I got this yes step right in your
back eyeball like a cancerous growth oh
man we are combination of like the
things from legend of zelda ocarina of
time you know what I'm talking about
Oh get out of here
ah just like that that's not fair that's
not fair
boo hulky bull honky bull honky
okay now that I know what to do okay I I
should dodge a mill or else that'll
happen I don't know if he could just get
tired out or if like if I have to hit
him and get him Neal
I'm gonna use my bullets
I did not expect a game like this Deb
boss battle so this is not surprising
man you are creepy man
you would be a great normal enemy if
you're just trying to hunt me down
okay I don't think he tires out
yeah okay all right when I have to
reload come on Otto when you're back
okay I got to switch to the knife
because otherwise it doesn't seem to be
doing and now
right in your back all get song
okay I got this not gonna fail out of
your fast getting faster or something
oh no I'm tired I'm tired oh [ __ ]
min-joo good I'm tired I'm tired Bologna
Bologna Bologna Bologna okay I'm tired
I'm switching to the gun dad good for
you alright when I have to reload again
okay guys that's not mine
ah get Sol's yeah Oh pwnage yep switch
the gun I should probably try to be a
bit more accurate
oh that was close okay I got this guy's
I got this a moment
I've almost got just one more ah come on
I'm tired I'm tired I'm fired him ha ha
ha oh come on speed up man speed up my
goodness
let's get him just get him just gonna
he's almost there oh he's almost there
ah he's almost there there we go okay
gun yeah okay fine
admit defeat hardcore style oh oh come
on man
really really really that guy's been
through all that with me by his side and
he throws up and passes out what a wuss
okay oh man
okay all right whoo boy did I pass out
yeah you did all right who's that who's
that yeah I got a gun Oh uh-huh sure you
hear that
and nobody you're somebody like you
shouldn't be here it's very no kiddin
wait why are you wearing a gas mask oh
no after you buddy I can't cook you I
don't know if you're real yeah I'm
realizing you on go away why were you
even in here I don't trust you all right
oh that was all just chapter one huh oh
this is gonna be a long game and I love
it love it I love this game I love this
game
kinda no seriously though I do I do like
this game a lot I love love the scares
it's kidding me I mean hi oh that guy oh
my god tried that trick on me
haha stop it stop it you're getting a
gun two bullets that's all it took a
panics on the other one in emptied an
entire clip into him so that was stupid
okay yeah but I'm actually loving this
game so far I hope you're enjoying my
reactions cuz whoo boy hi
just so long as I don't run into that
scary lady again it's all I care about
it's all I care about Cicilline is
everything all right okay there was
someone left dead what is wrong with you
what is wrong with you
okay what's it anything
something
nothing
and why are these rooms here if there's
nothing I don't know I don't know
all right moving on hello again another
useless room all outside finally oh my
goodness oh it's about time
not that I imagine this is gonna be any
better but ha ha
I know so dang good
oh dang ba one shot all it takes is a
headshot man
kill aah they died come on right your
face hot dog throw dog pet shop there we
go
Jihu what is going on with your face
buddy did picasso have a turn at y'all
with a hacksaw left oh okay
Isis articles for the modern man
depression I don't know most of you too
dirty to make out but it seems to be an
article about depression
sounds familiar well five four three two
one for today I'll call that number with
my phone machine maybe
nope all I can do is use the flashlight
alright I got to cut it here but thank
you guys so much for watching I really
do appreciate it and I hope you're
enjoying this game as much as I and I
will see you in the next part
bye bye